[Music]
hi everyone thank you for coming and
watching my session which is going to be
Android on large screens so as we all
know Android has evolved from just being
a phone platform it's available on
watches and cars as we just heard
desktop phones and specifically the
mobile space has also changed pretty
drastically let's see what your mobile
apk is running on today so starting off
with the phone it's what we all
developed for mainly if not solely a
couple keys about the platform its
portrait first touch first and
full-screen first a lot of apps now even
lock rotation some users do obviously
use multi window or stylus and things
like that but majority of your users are
using it with regular touchscreens and
in full screen
moving on to tablets both orientations
here are kind of first-class citizens if
you do lock the portrait users can still
use your app in the portrait landscape
larger screens do bring challenges
design-wise but also the ability to kind
of do different things take more
advantage of the real estate allow your
users to do things faster but more
importantly the the different medium
kind of brings a different focus on what
apps are probably going to be used more
heavily content apps or media
consumption apps productivity apps
things that can really take advantage of
the larger screen and then moving on to
kind of the desktop platforms you know
we have Chrome OS we have some om that
have made desktop platforms as well like
the Samsung duck stock the huawei mate
desktop mode also Android is now brought
the ability to really take advantage of
having external displays so it's very
possible that your app even if it's
running on a phone is actually being
displayed to an external monitor this is
really where the biggest difference
comes in where it's landscape first all
these environments have some sort of
window resizing and multi windows going
to be used a lot more often and you have
new first class input methods such as
keyboard and mouse and track pads that
actually either ship with the device or
will be connected so what's a focus on
when you're thinking about kind of how
to bring your apps to all these
platforms and have a good user
experience
number one is design you know again if
you've really been focusing on on phones
most your designs are probably very
portrait based and kind of smaller
screen base window management is
probably the biggest place where we see
issues with partners apps dealing with
resizing some multi window
considerations things like that are just
problems we've never had to focus before
and then we're gonna talk a little bit
about the tooling that's available from
Google to make sure that you're able to
actually develop for these platforms and
bring it into your actual cycle so
talking about design raise your hands if
you have layouts for large screens or
tablets at all a lot more people and I
expected cool so you know biggest thing
is just thinking about larger screens
again you've probably for the last
couple years we've seen a lot more apps
come out that that may lock the portrait
or are solely mobile focused which makes
sense but with the more more and more
like growing number of platforms that
are running your mold apk but showing a
completely different form factor or
platform it's time to start thinking
again about how to really bring the best
experience those areas I'm a really bad
example of design is actually Google
Play Music which is always great so a
couple things about this that that
really are not great is Super Stretch
layout there's tons of white space that
could be used to show more content to
the user whether it's like album
descriptions artist descriptions album
art things like that the biggest key
here though is there's no line dividers
which on a phone is fine because the
screen is so small you can see what
options menu you're clicking on when you
take it to kind of a larger landscape
scant landscape layout it's really hard
to actually follow the lines and see
what item your pricing options menu for
a an external partner that we worked a
lot with actually is one password so
looking at their phone layouts it's kind
of your standard list of items that you
will drill down into but when you move
to a larger screen they really take
advantage of the real estate going to
almost like a three panel layout
allowing the user to really get whatever
content they need and a lot less clicks
and a lot faster also being able to
showcase more information at the same
time so kind of going back to the same
point is again just building layouts for
both orientations and there's a couple
of big keys for this again not all
platforms are portrait first a lot of
the desktop environments if you're only
really building for portrait you're
gonna have a pretty bad user experience
when I want to use your app and let's
say fullscreen or even just the top half
of the screen if I'm trying to multitask
on top of that resizing capabilities
allow the user to make your out whatever
size orientation or screen ratio that
they really want to so you really want
to let the user really decide how they
want to use your app going back to kind
of mainly the desktop platforms is
designing for input mediums other than
touch make sure your design is taken
into consideration like how your app
works maybe using a mouse or stylus and
things like that on top of this the UX
patterns for different non-touch are
different for non touch devices things
like right-clicking is a little bit
different than what we kind of are used
to with long pressing most of the
paradigms are long pressing to multi
select items whereas when you
right-click on a desktop
you're usually expecting some type of
pop-up context menu and things like that
I'm still taking the time to really
think about how your app works with the
different new yorks considerations the
other big one that we notice is hover
actions on on the web or on desktop
environments for the mouse you really
expect some type of feedback when you
move your mouse like over an action item
to let you know that there is actually
something you can do there whether it's
clickable or draggable there's some
behavior there's some feedback myself
even if I use the app on phone
extensively Google Google Drive is a
good example of this when I use it on
let's say Android on Chrome OS I'll miss
actions that I can actually do because
just natively on this platform I'm
expecting some type of of hover actions
I'm going to go over to simple api's
there are many API was like kind of help
handle a lot of these input methods and
things such as like Mau scrolling and
things like that and they'll be
resources when the slides get posted but
right-clicking which is really one of
the usual kind of feature blocks is
super easy you just set an on context
click listener and make sure that you're
exposing whatever behavior or
functionality you have on long press in
this method again also hopefully
considering any type of UX changes you
need to make and then sitting a hover
listener to kind of watch for the users
points or hovering over the item and and
out again this is really the biggest one
we see that will lead to kind of miss
functionality or the kind of really give
you the the desktop native feel or even
just kind of the large screen native
feel in terms of hovering most of our
native components do you handle this
somewhat but depending on the colors
you're using the contrast and change may
not be enough for you or your users or
especially accessibility things like
that at the end of the day though you
know how your users you see app and you
know the product so you know take some
time and use your app on kind of these
different platforms and think about how
you would expect the app to behave
things that you would expect the app to
take advantage of note taking out the
stylus based may not really need to
focus much on on mouse input or keyboard
import input where a Productivity app is
really going to want to take advantage
of all the screen real estate and find
ways to let the users do what they need
to do as fast as possible so talking
about window management this
again is the really the biggest area
where we see crashes happen because it's
just challenges that we've never had to
face before and kind of a mobile-only
environment
I love harping on rotation because I see
so many apps that lock to portrait which
is completely understandable but on
these different platforms it really
shows kind of where the experience falls
if you do lock to portrait on Chrome s
physically this is how your app will
look like you'll get these super cool
black bars on the side and it's really
just a whole bunch of wasted screen real
estate on top of that it also really
shows the user and gives this really non
native feel just because it doesn't
really conform to the platform well now
why do we generally lock to portrait
usually to run away from handling
configuration changes because they've
always been rather difficult to deal
with but on these larger screen
platforms configuration changes are more
important than ever
resizing and multi-window brings a lot
of new kind of configuration change
paradigms and challenges Chrome OS is
probably one of the most complex of the
resizing strategies because it does
trigger configuration changes pretty
frequently I know some of the other
desktop platforms don't cause as many
configuration changes on top of that
with bigger screens multi-window is
going to be used much more frequently
than before so any bugs that you do have
in that are going to start kind of being
surfaced a lot a lot more
this is a quick jiff about just kind of
Howry site resizing on Chrome OS works
so any any time one of those labels
changes it's going through a complete
destroy and rebuild process so you can
imagine that this can get triggered
substantially faster and substantially
more often than on a phone just because
rotation is just kind of slow jetpack
helps with this the things like v-model
I'm being able to build your own
components that are life cycle where I
really allows you to kind of take any of
your business logic
in your activity anything you're doing
to save state and and move it there so
that your activity destroy and rebuild
process is really quick your app will
not always be in focus again this isn't
new with Android I'm n like we brought
multi-window
but on these larger screens you're going
to see this being the case a lot more
often I know most of us at work with a
large monitor have multiple things up at
once and you need to make sure that your
content is still visible and playing
even if you're not the focused app so
make sure that you're still displaying
messages if your messaging app or your
content um is continuing playing and
then take advantage of the features on
these new and different platforms larger
screens and external monitors bring new
possibilities one of the things that
we've seen a couple apps do such as
email apps or word processing apps that
that really kind of bring a better
experience is allowing you know come
mail come compose Windows or new
documents be shown a different tasks so
that the user can really see their email
Plus this new email they're creating in
a different window something that that
we released quite a bit ago but is now
really being used a lot more as drag and
drop
again these desktop platforms
specifically users expect drag and drop
to be a thing they're not really going
to understand that this is an Android
app and we've never thought about it
before so why doesn't this exist so
think about if drag and drop kind of
makes sense in your app and and how you
can kind of bring it to these platforms
and they're not really window management
but different features that are kind of
new to some of these ecosystems is just
info Kate
different like info capabilities and
specifically like increased stylus usage
the biggest things that we've seen that
users have have loved on some of the
apps that we've worked with is the
ability to have keyboard shortcuts and
keyboard navigation so that if they're
heavy power users or there's things that
people do often they're able to do these
things faster get in and out of the app
get what they need to get done as as
quick as possible so this is great in
all but how do we actually build for
this and moving on to tooling
you know it'd be awful if I came up here
and talked about kind of you should do
all these things yet there's no tools
from us to make this possible
most of the tooling devices that we do
have our tooling examples that we do
have or are around Chrome OS a it's our
platform and then B it's also kind of
the most all-in-one platform that we
have most devices ship with a keyboard
and trackpad some don't even have a
touchscreen and then it has one of the
more complex resizing strategies so it's
kind of the best all-in-one platform to
test on we're working on bringing some
interest to the integrations
specifically around larger screens and
Chrome OS lint additions are coming soon
it's actually my job once that's events
over to finish this and then we're
really looking at more things that we
can bring to the IDE it's really great
to have devices that you can test on but
we want to be able to give quicker
feedback and things to look for while
you're actually developing in the IDE so
if you have ideas please come let me
know there's a Chrome OS emulator that's
currently in preview so if you don't
have devices you can download the
emulator and start to kind of see where
your out falls apart things that don't
work things that crash things you know
etc one of the biggest complaints for
developing for Chrome OS and testing has
been having to use ADB of a Wi-Fi and
the development cycle has always been
pretty crappy but on the HP Chromebook
x2 in the pixel book you can adb over
USB so you can actually bring the
devices into the same kind of
development cycle that you do with
phones other devices still require a to
be over Wi-Fi but we hope to bring more
and more or more more devices to this
feature but the easiest way really is
just to run Android studio and Chrome OS
this is available currently on the pixel
book in preview and we're hoping to
bring it to more devices in the future
and we do have this set up at the
Android and Chrome OS tables as well as
the Android studio table being able to
just kind of build the app and deploy it
directly to the device makes the whole
development cycles substantially easier
and fast
at the end of the day Android is always
evolving there's more and more platforms
that are running apks whether they're
different flavors or even just your
mobile IP apk so make sure that your app
is - thank you again please ask any
questions any suggestions that you have
for tooling any things that you've run
into when trying to develop for kind of
larger screen platforms I would love to
hear about it so that we can tackle this
thank you
[Music]